oh thanks Frogger wreckit-ralph - is
finally in cinemas and it's even more
amazing than we thought it will be but
do you know the voices behind every
single character stay tuned to find out
which two extremely famous youtubers got
a part in wreck-it Ralph - do you love
Disney make sure to hit that like and
subscribe button for even more fun now
let's check out the behind the scenes of
wreck-it Ralph - character voices arene
Bedard as Pocahontas let's start with a
voice actress that has so much energy
just looking at her makes you smile
Irene Bedard is the original speaking
voice of Pocahontas so it's only fair
she portrayed Pocahontas in wreck-it
Ralph - what kind of a princess are you
I am the voice of Pocahontas in the film
and I'm also your guide for this
behind-the-scenes adventure Irene is
actually a Native American in real life
so she definitely does justice to
Pocahontas is character and although
she's a bundle of energy her voice is so
incredibly soothing it makes us close
our eyes and pretend we're back in the
original movie Kristen Bell as Anna
Kristen Bella is one of those hashtag
relatable actresses you just can't help
but love she's absolutely hilarious it's
a holiday when we celebrate a movie
about a brother and a sister who kiss
of course she's the voice of Anna in
frozen but did you know that she's also
the voice of Gossip Girl her character
gets revealed right at the end and no
one even suspects the theme you are not
going to along with returning to voice
Anna in wreck-it Ralph - Christian has
had major success as we'll be seeing her
again in frozen - you can also catch her
in a hilarious show at the good place
and one of our favorites Veronica Mars
is finally returning on Hulu for its
fourth season
she's definitely a busy one isn't she
Jodi Benson as Ariel
although Alyssa Milano was the one that
gave Ariel her look Jodi Benson gave her
her voice check her out here recording
part of your world this video belongs to
RDO dolly & Co who did an awesome job
capturing Jodi getting familiar with
this
we all know and love
[Music]
isn't she adorable we can't imagine
anyone else giving Ariel or her boys so
it only makes sense that she returned
for the wreckit-ralph to Disney Princess
reunion Jodi's voice is still
recognizable isn't it
soon he made a deal with an underwater
sealing where she took your voice in
exchange for a pair of human legs
seriously Jodi is the most perfect Ariel
oddly each ravallo as mallanna speaking
of perfect Disney princesses we still
can't believe that Ali he practically
looks like Moana and it was all a
coincidence
it's like Moana in real life I could be
the perfect daughter but I coming back
to the water one of the reasons why Elly
is the perfect Moana is also because
Disney definitely did its research to
make sure Pacific Islanders are
represented correctly
[Music]
although mallanna didn't really say much
in wreckit-ralph - we're still so happy
she was there she's not considered a
disney princess by the official
standards but she's definitely a Disney
princess in our own lineup Jennifer Hale
as Cinderella okay here's the thing
Jennifer Hale isn't the original voice
of Cinderella the original belongs style
Ian Woods who unfortunately passed away
in 2010 since then Jennifer took her
place as Cinderella in various games and
other appearances here's what she looks
like it was wonderful
but Cinderella is not the only character
Jennifer voices in fact you can find her
voice in some of your fate video games
she even crossed over to another world
and gave voice to Alana in the Little
Mermaid Ariel's beginning a true
multi-talented voice actress isn't she
Kate Higgins as Aurora meets Kate
Higgins the voice behind one of the most
forgotten Disney Princesses ever
although kate is not the original voice
of Aurora she gave the character a voice
in Sofia the first although the original
Aurora voice actress is still alive she
wasn't brought back for the
wreckit-ralph to role Kate said it
herself that Aurora might not have a lot
of lines but then she added this which
is most definitely true I mean she's a
classic you know and they they treated
it like that
although Aurora doesn't speak much it
would be nice to see this classic role
rebooted in the future don't you think
put a modern twist to it Disney Linda
Larkin as jasmine Disney fans have
always pointed out that Linda Larkin the
original voice of Jasmine is incredibly
kind in real life just like an actual
Disney Princess you can really hear the
actual Jasmine in this clip I want to
thank you for stopping that man not many
people would have done that jasmine
delivers one of the best lines when she
asks vanellope if she has daddy issues
see it for yourself do you have daddy
issues no mom we love the meta humor
that's going on in the Disney Princess
parts of the movie and yep we'll be
getting a live remake of Aladdin in 2019
but unfortunately Linda won't be
returning as Jasmine so make sure you
get enough of her adorable voice in
wreck-it Ralph - Kelly Macdonald has
Merida Kelly Macdonald is an original
Merida and she made a return in the
wreck-it Ralph - movie
we all collectively lost it when we saw
the extended clip of vanellope and other
princesses looking slightly confused
with her accent and pure mass I don't
know West here's what Kelly looks like
in real life
her hair is definitely not as big or
curly as Merida's but she definitely has
the accent firstborn descendent of
Merida is one of those characters that's
just so unique to Disney's portfolio we
just can't help but feel proud of her
accomplishments and by the looks of it
Kelly is just as fond of her character
as we are idina menzel
as Elsa and here comes the let it go
Queen I also really changed the game
when it came to Disney Princesses and
she's not even on the official princess
list but idina menzel is without a doubt
a princess in her own right we bet a lot
of people can actually relate to else's
character but Idina is just so sweet she
didn't even take it to heart when John
Travolta made this unfortunate mistake
of pronouncing her name wrong please
welcome the wickedly talented one and
only a true Queen isn't she still
waiting for Disney to officially crown
her and Anna as princesses Mandy Moore
as Rapunzel the name Mandy Moore
probably doesn't ring a bell if you were
born anywhere after 2005 but nineties
babies might remember Mandy Moore from
Princess Diaries no seriously she was in
Princess Diaries stupid cube stop it
and she's also Rapunzel in the original
tangled movie as well as in
wreckit-ralph - here she is spilling
some meta truth about Disney Princesses
do you have daddy issues notice that
right before this moment Rapunzel was
the only one that didn't join in when
princesses announced that they don't
have a mom and now for the million
dollar question she's among the handful
that actually does we absolutely adore
Mandy's voice and we hope this isn't the
last time she'll be reprising her role
as Rapunzel pamela ribbon as Snow White
the original melodic voice of Snow White
belongs to adriana caselotti but after
Adriana's passing pamela ribbon insured
to carry on the legacy honestly we can't
believe they got away with it either
Pamela did a great job bringing
snow-white back to life and giving her
that sweet melodic voice again even
though Snow White has been criticized
for her stereotypical role it's nice to
see her hang out with some of the more
modern Disney Princesses anika Noni Rose
as Tiana speaking of classic princesses
Tiana is perhaps the most underrated
ones out of all she's definitely a
princess that isn't exactly fit to the
standard stereotypes and her voice
actress anika Noni Rose absolutely loves
the role in case you don't know Anika
was actually Laurel in Dreamgirls that's
right a dizzy princessing next up
Beyonce
seriously Anika has an amazing voice
just look at her casually belting high
notes
even though Tiana didn't say much in
wreckit-ralph to movie it was amazing
seeing Anika reprise her role as one of
our faith Disney Princesses Minah when
as Mulan here's another voice actress
that's been pretty busy since portraying
Mulan in the original movie her name is
Mina when and she's absolutely adorable
with all due respect your excellency I
think I've been away from home long
enough if she looks familiar you
probably know her from playing Melinda
May in Marvel's agents of shield how
about I do you a favor and not tell
anyone that a tiny little Asian woman
kicked her yep
Melinda Mae is secretly a Disney
Princess of course Ming Na when does a
fantastic job as Mulan and it's so nice
to see her back in Disney action
speaking of action
unfortunately ming-na wen won't be
returning to portray Mulan in the
live-action movie coming in 2020 so make
sure you watch wreck-it Ralph too for
your dose of OG Mulan john c reilly as
ralph and now let's move on to other
actors that made wreck-it ralph - what
it is and one of those actors is without
a doubt john c reilly who plays the one
and only ralph youtube-channel the a/v
Club shared a funny video of John
explaining what it's like to be a voice
actor for a Ralph oh honey look who it
is it's record Ralph and the kids like
no it's not it looks nothing like
wreck-it Ralph he went on to explain
that kids seem to think Ralph is an
actual real character that would be
absolutely hilarious if that were true
we're still giggling about this moment
from the movie Sarah Silverman and who
could possibly forget about the new
addition to the Disney Princess family
the one and only vanellope
she's voiced by Sarah Silverman who of
course also voiced vanilla pee in the
first movie
seriously her original voice is sort of
similar to vanilla peas and it's equally
as adorable you can kind of hear her
cartoon voice coming out right Sarah is
extremely proud of her role as Penelope
who by the way is actually the first
Jewish Disney Princess that's a huge
thing for Disney as well as it's
conspiracy theorists but that's a topic
for another video let's move on to some
other voice actors gal gadot as Shane
everyone collectively screamed when gal
gadot was added to the wreckit-ralph to
cast list we loved her in Wonder Woman
and we loved her even more as shank and
wreck-it Ralph - there's no law saying
best friends have to have the same
dreams
Ralph refers to her as that shank lady
which is absolutely hilarious in real
life gal gadot is far from a
tough-as-nails type of character good
yeah for little children seriously she's
pretty goofy this was actually gal gadot
first time doing voiceover work and we
have a feeling this is only the
beginning
taraji P Henson as yes yes which by the
way is spelled as yes with two extra
less letters is one of the most perfect
characters she's the algorithm the same
algorithm that tells us when something
comes on her feed on YouTube Facebook
and Instagram
[Music]
she's voiced by taraji P Henson who has
an extensive acting resume if her voice
sounds familiar
you probably remember her as the mom
from Jaden Smith's Karate Kid you heard
I'm he ran into a pole don't start
taraji said that getting that
wreckit-ralph call was like a dream come
true and something she got to cross off
her bucket lists that must have been a
pretty awesome feeling Jack McBrayer as
Felix everyone had one question when we
first heard about the second movie is
Felix going to be in it well of course
he is Felix is played by Jack McBrayer
who also played herbing in Phineas and
Ferb you allow me to introduce myself
I'm curving wreckit-ralph wouldn't be
complete without him Jack said that
Felix in him
looked quite alike and they even
captured some of the same features in
his animated character he said that the
entire experience of filming the second
movie was just way too fun and we can
imagine why it looks awesome to work
behind the scenes on wreck-it Ralph to
Jane Lynch as Calhoun one of the most
distinctive voices in wreck-it Ralph is
without a doubt Jane Lynch Calhoun is a
fan favorite character and we're so
happy to see Jane Lynch back in the
second movie Kohut my cruiser
[Applause]
of course the romance between her and
Felix is our absolute favorite Side
Story in wreck-it Ralph as you already
know Jane Lynch is just as hilarious
behind the scenes as she is in the movie
who can forget her role as Sue Sylvester
in Glee look at me even in the heat of
battle I'm so elegant we love her just
as much as we love our last two voice
actresses glozell green as Little Debbie
glozell might have a minor part in the
movie but since she's a fellow youtuber
we just have to give her credit if you
have never seen her content you
absolutely have to check her out because
she's hilarious bck online YouTube
channel caught up with her at the red
carpet premiere of the second movie
seriously she's so funny but fans were
really excited to catch a glimpse of an
even bigger YouTube star Colleen
ballinger as herself
due to recent changes Colleen ballinger
went through in her YouTube career it's
absolutely heartwarming to see Colleen
aka Miranda sings being a part of this
movie the movie also pays homage to
several other digital influencers but
fans were literally screaming when they
saw a short clip of Colleen what and
although she's credited as Colleen and
not Miranda sings you can sort of hear
her Miranda character it's even more
heartwarming because earlier this year
Colleen announced that she's saying
goodbye to Miranda at least for a while
what a lovely tribute
huh there's something missing
Nickelodeon has been giving us iconic
cartoon characters for decades but have
you ever wondered who's behind the
voices of these animated legends
[Music]
sorry mr. Krabs but my new philosophy is
scary equals funny
you'll be surprised to find out that Hey
Arnold isn't actually voiced by a
football head or that a surprising
amount of male cartoons were voiced by
women
keep watching to see the people who
bring your favorite Nick characters to
life this first voice actor will come as
a total shock
Nickelodeon's Rugrats is one of the most
successful shows of all time it followed
a bunch of toddlers and all of their
grand adventures the ringleader was
Tommy pickles he kept a screwdriver and
his diaper to bust all the Rugrats out
of the playpen millions of Millennials
can still hear Tommy scratchy voice but
he was actually voiced by a woman named
Elizabeth Daly she voiced him again in
all grown-up she's responsible for some
other iconic characters too Elizabeth
was the voice of buttercup in Powerpuff
Girls it's hard to believe that Tommy
and Buttercup are really the same person
The Adventures of Jimmy Neutron boy
genius first air in 2003 it was one of
Nickelodeon's early computer animated
series James Isaac neutron who went by
Jimmy was a genius and inventor in the
fifth grade he created all sorts of
advanced - technologies that usually
ended up getting him and his friends
into trouble but Jimmy wasn't voiced by
a fifth-grade boy he was voiced by a
woman named Debbie Derryberry Debbie has
been voice acting for a long time to me
all my characters they can sound the
same it's my voice she played Diana on
both series of Sailor Moon
she even voiced through the title
character from JJ the jet plane recently
she was Maureen on f is for family
SpongeBob SquarePants is one of the
longest-running kids series ever it's
been on for over 20 years
the yellow eager sponge has become a
complete cultural icon Sponge Bob might
be the single most recognizable cartoon
character in history you know I never
took the driver's test with long pants
but we bet you can't picture who voices
them Tom Kenny has been voicing
Spongebob since the very beginning but
that high-pitched sponge is just one of
many voices Tom has over 491 credits on
IMDB and some of those shows involved
voicing multiple characters his next big
project is Pinocchio in The Adventures
of Pinocchio we hope Tom is willing to
stick around in bikini bottom for a few
more years one crazy animal two voices
cat dog first aired in 1998 it followed
a cat and a dog who were conjoined they
had different personalities and got into
all sorts of mischief cat is a proper
tidy animal white fish chub dog is goofy
and unrefined cat is voiced by Jim
Cummings who was very famous in the
voice-acting world
he's been the voice of Winnie the Pooh
and Tigger for decades let's get he has
over 500 acting credits on IMDB you've
probably heard him in tons of cartoons
and movies dog is voiced by none other
than Tom Kenny yeah that's right dog and
spongebob are voiced by the same person
we couldn't believe it
Nickelodeon just doesn't make shows for
older kids they are also famous for
their Nick jr. shows for preschoolers
Dora the Explorer was on the air for 19
years the show taught kids some Spanish
and also how to follow directions unlike
a lot of cartoons Dora has gone through
three different voice actors the first
was Kathleen air leis who was just 10
years old when she started she was the
longest-running Dora with over 100
episodes
swipe the present from 2008 to 2014
Caitlyn Sanchez voiced the character
cartoon she was 12 when she started and
she appears to have left show business
after Dora the final Dora was Fatima
pattach ik d actress is now 20 years old
she stars in an upcoming film called
coast I identify because I felt that way
about Dora when I was younger
Nickelodeon's the loud house is one of
their current animated series it's a
great show all about a boy living with
his huge family Lincoln loud is a great
relatable character the road house has
been on since 2016 but Lincoln has
already had three voice actors the show
has hired three boys but at that age
their voices start to change they keep
having to find new kids to voice the
lead character first up is Colin Dean he
was on the show from 2016 until 2018
next up is grant Palmer he actually
voiced some episodes at the same time
ask Colin but then he started voicing
other characters most recently Lincoln
has been voiced by Tex Hammond want to
know who's behind the voice of an even
more iconic middle school boy keep
watching to find out this next character
wasn't on a show but he's a Nickelodeon
icon nonetheless tons of kids in the
1990s and early 2000s grew up watching
the mascot Nick jr. he came on between
shows as face and face was literally
just a face we all remember his tagline
hi there face here so who was the voice
actor behind face Chris Phillips first
voiced the character he is still doing
voice acting but most recently was on
butter beans cafe in faces last year he
was voiced by Bobby Floyd you might know
him as the performer of the pokerap from
pokemons here's a question I wonder what
today's question will be Rocko's Modern
Life was a popular Nickelodeon cartoon
that was on from 1993 to 1996
it's a strange a surrealist show about
an Australian wallaby who lives in
America let's just say a lot of the
humor wouldn't have made it into today's
shows Rocco was voiced by the successful
voice actor carlos alazraqui he's still
in the nickelodeon family playing Carlos
on the loud house and the casagrandes
he's also a regular actor and has
appeared as deputy Garcia on many
episodes of Reno 911 Heffer wolf is
another familiar face you guessed it Tom
Kenny aka Sponge Bob I can't wait to
show Rocko it's hard to pick a favorite
character from the Rugrats but Chuckie
would definitely be one of our top
choices Tommy's best friend has a lot of
issues they were very different but it
worked
whereas tommy was brave Chuckie was
timid and afraid of everything who can
forget his shaky and nasally voice just
like Tommy Chuckie was voiced by an
adult woman this woman's name is
Christine Cavanaugh and you won't
believe where else you've heard her
voice
Christine was the voice of Dexter in
Dexter's Laboratory she also voiced the
world's most famous talking pig in babe
Christine was definitely one of the most
iconic voice actors of her time I can't
tell you how grateful I am to y'all
Nickelodeon's most famous magical couple
is none other than Cosmo and Wanda these
fairies were Timmy's constant companions
on the fairies OddParents and let's just
say they weren't always the greatest at
helping Timmy out these three got into a
lot of trouble
[Music]
timmy turner daran Norris voiced cosmo
on the show he voiced to Timmy's dad
mr Turner too he also does on-screen
acting you might know him as Johnny
Forrest from I zombie or cliff from
Veronica Mars Wanda and mrs. Turner were
voiced by Suzanne Blakesley recently
Suzanne has played mrs. Johnson on the
loud house she is also old lady Crowley
untangled the series everyone loves the
grumpy cynical co-worker of Sponge Bob
Squidward Tentacles is such a great
character because everyone knows a
person just like him Squidward really
puts up with a lot from SpongeBob and
Patrick that's me but the guy who voices
him looks way less grumpy Rodger Bumpass
is the voice actor behind Squidward he's
also voiced to several extra characters
on SpongeBob as well
Roger is no stranger to Nickelodeon he
voiced professor membrane on invader zim
and by klopse on chalk zone right now he
is working exclusively on spongebob
roger has been acting since 1979 he
voiced a bunch of characters on the
original series Alvin and the Chipmunks
and finally / two idiots equals stupid
in 2004 Nickelodeon launched a brand new
animated show called Danny Phantom Danny
Fenton was a normal teenage kid until he
got ghost powers then he became aware of
all of this crazy supernatural stuff
going on in his world he became a
superhero
as an expiration day here is you when
used his powers to save the world on a
regular basis all while trying to be a
normal team danny was voiced by David
Kaufman David has appeared on screen and
several guest roles and shows like The
Mentalist
he's also voiced to Stuart Little in the
short animated series way back in the
early 90s he was the voice of Marty
McFly on a short-lived animated version
of Back to the Future
he is reprising his role as Danny
Phantom in the upcoming nostalgia show
Nicktoons the loud house introduced a
lot of great characters including Bobby
and Ronnie Ann these two characters are
now on a spin-off show about their own
big family they move to the big city and
meet their extended family the
casagrandes the casagrandes is all about
life in a large Latin family okay I
gotta find out who did this Ronnie Ann
is played by sixteen year old Isabella
Alvarez Isabella
appeared on a few episodes of shameless
in 2014 she also played Lawrence's
daughter on HBO's hit series Westworld
Bobby is voiced by Carlos Pena Vega the
30-year old got his start with
Nickelodeon on two episodes of Ned's
Declassified back in 2004 he has two
movies in the works right now
and and this scene was super fun they
had real fireworks Hey Arnold was one of
Nickelodeon's most popular series it
aired from 1996 until 2004 the show
followed a fourth grader named Arnold
and all of his friends through life in
the projects of a big city
Arnold actually had three different
voice actors and their time on the show
overlapped Layne tauren voice to the
most episodes as Arnold you might also
know him as King Bob from Disney's
recess then came Spencer Klein he hasn't
done any acting since the show ended
there's also Philippa Van Dyke he played
Luke in the first Halloween tail movie
on Disney Channel maybe I can show you
around sometime buy you an ice cream
in 1991 Nickelodeon premiered their
first ever animated series Doug was one
of the first along with Rugrats and ren
and stimpy doug was all about a boy
named doug funnie as he tried to
navigate life in middle school to please
thank you he had friends like Skeeter
Valentine and Patti mayonnaise and he
wrote in his diary about his life
Doug was eventually brought back by
Disney and continued until 1999 on Nick
Doug was voiced by Billy West Billy also
voiced both ren and stimpy he is slated
to reprise his roles in the new ren &
stimpy it's our house now video sure
when Doug moved to Disney the actor was
replaced by Thomas McHugh and that's a
wrap so who is your favorite Nickelodeon
cartoon character of all time let us
know in the comments to infinity and
your mom when's the last time you were
watching one of your favorite Disney
flicks
and thought to yourself I know that
voice you're not alone you'd be shocked
to see which stars are behind the mic of
some of your favorite animated
characters like the Harry Potter star
who you had no idea voice Disney royalty
so how many of these celebrity voice
actors can you guess let's find out
billy goat and gruff right right right
sorry guys girls girls of course the
actors they chose to voice moana was
definitely a perfect fit for the island
princess first of all she's from hawaii
so she knows all about life in the sand
and second she looks pretty much exactly
like moana do you know who she is
it's Allie eek ravallo don't be
surprised if you couldn't place her
voice Moana was out Leah's very first
role
since then she's gone on to sing live at
the Oscars plays Ariel in the Little
Mermaid live on ABC and Boyce Moana
again in Ralph breaks the internet talk
about living a fairy tale the star who
played Maui also looks a lot like the
character he voiced you know Maui is the
hero to all you doing great this gentle
giant loves fast cars skyscrapers and
Jumanji he's also a retired professional
wrestler think you know him of course
it's the rock Dwayne Johnson really
wanted to play Maui so he could be a
part of the Disney family and represent
his Samoan roots at the same time he
even played cheerleader behind the
scenes and made it his mission to keep
the cast encouraged and motivated which
sounds exactly like something the rock
would do the celebrity who gave her
voice to mah Lana's mom Sina is more of
a singer than an actress she's been a
judge on the masked singer dated ed
Sheeran oh and she's also a Pussycat
Doll sometimes who we wish we were what
we wish we could do so who do you think
it is that's right
it's singer dancer and voice actress
Nicole Scherzinger like her Moana
co-star alii nicole was also born in
Hawaii and after Moana she went on to
voice another Disney character Moe's mom
in Ralph breaks the Internet Ralph
breaks the Internet brought back all the
major Disney Princesses but what's even
more fun is who they got to voice them
let's start with Ariel's I have to
assume you made a deal with an
underwater see the actress who brought
her voice to the role is no stranger to
Disney she was Barbie in Toy Story 3 and
voiced Helen of Troy in the hercules TV
series do you think you know who it is
it's Jodi Benson and if that means
sounds familiar it's probably because
you know her from her most famous role
the original voice of Ariel in the
Little Mermaid I don't see how a world
that makes such wonderful things
could be bad she's also the one who
sings Oliverio songs
so next time you're rockin out - part of
your world you have Jodi to think what
about Pocahontas Disney wanted to make
sure they got a Native American woman to
voice the original role so of course
they wanted to do the same in Ralph
breaks the Internet what kind of a
princess are you they decided to go with
someone who'd been Pocahontas before do
you know who they chose it's the
phenomenal
Irene Bedard the original Pocahontas the
character design for the princess was
actually modeled after Irene so she
brings a lot more than her voice to the
role this is how we say hello Wynn got
BA in 1995 she made People magazine's 50
most beautiful people list so by now
you've probably noticed that Disney
likes to bring back their original
princesses they did the same thing with
Belle in Ralph's breaks the internet
well there's a lot to unpack here so
this steering wheel you sing of the
actress who voiced her was the original
Belle back in 1991 and starred as
Fantine in Leh miserab on Broadway do
you know her it's Paige O'Hara who
auditioned five times for the role of
Belle because she wanted it so badly and
good thing she got it because she's been
Belle in Ralph's breaks the internet
both Beauty and the Beast sequels and
video games like Kingdom Hearts peed
really is Belle the voice of Rapunzel
entangled has a weird talent for making
us cry in a walk to remember and this is
us she's always pulling on our
heartstrings
oh and she was also a pop star as a
teenager do you know who she is it's
Mandy Moore Mandy says she takes being a
disney princess very seriously though
she's also been the villain a couple
times she played Mia's bully Atlanta in
The Princess Diaries but still she much
prefers being Rapunzel she even voiced
the character again in Ralph breaks the
Internet
do people assume all your problems got
solved because a big strong man showed
up the voice actor they chose to play
Flynn is just as funny in real life
can't you picture me in a castle of my
own because I certainly can he recently
made his big-screen debut as a superhero
and Shazam
he was also Fandral in Thor any idea who
he could be
it's Zachary Levi who described playing
a Disney Prince as a bucket-list dream
the only downside to being entangled
Mandy and Zach had to record all their
dialogue alone Zach hopes that the next
animated project he does will be a bit
more social and we can't help but agree
so you probably know the amazing
actresses who bring Elsa and Anna to
life in frozen but what about some of
the other major characters who appear in
the sequel let's start with clean I do
know herself when I was little my mother
would sing a song about a special river
called aha Elsa and Ana's mom is an
amazing singer the actress who gave her
her voice has starred in Westworld and
across the universe where she got to
show off her amazing voice do you know
who she is
clean Idina is Evan Rachel Wood she was
born into a musical family with parents
who can both act and sing but Evans
admitted that her children aren't so
hyped about her technically being a
Disney princess now instead they always
ask her questions about Josh dad who
voices Olaf lightning-round
boys against girls
Mandy Moore isn't the only this is a
star to voice a Disney character one of
her children from the hit show took on
the role of lieutenant matias in frozen
- any idea who he is
yep it's sterling K Brown while Sterling
tends to go for live-action roles like
the one in black panther frozen -
actually wasn't his first animated film
he also voiced scary in Angry Birds -
where he actually got to work with Josh
GAD for the first time he voiced Chuck
okay so Kristoff and Anna are totally
meant to be but who is it that voice is
the iconic character alongside Kristen
Bell yes now back up while I deal with
this crook here you know this performer
from Glee where he ended up with the one
and only Rachel Berry
after making us all fall in love with
his voice do you remember him it's
Jonathan Groff an actor and singer who
got his start on Broadway right
alongside Lea Michele
he also played King George in Hamilton
but the best news ever is that Groff
would love the chance to play Kristoff
in frozen on Broadway we need tickets
stat brothers Ian and Bailey from onward
are kind of like brothers in real life
these two actors are known for their
roles as comedic superheroes
one of them's really into spiders while
the other is more of a star-lord can you
guess who they are it's Tom Holland and
Chris Pratt the duo had so much fun
behind the scenes they literally lost
their voices the actors who both have
brothers of their own made time in their
busy schedules to film together as much
as possible
don't these two make work look fun the
actors chosen to voice on words
Manticore is one of Hollywood's biggest
names she won both an Oscar and a Golden
Globe for her role in the help and she
was also recently the voice of a little
duck named dab dab in Dolittle so what's
your best guess of course it's Octavia
Spencer I
you used to be typecast in small roles
often as a nurse before she skyrocketed
to fame after the help since then she's
been in countless movies like hidden
figures and instant family and now she's
even played a Manticore the comedian
cast as officer gore is known for being
a baby Cobra and a hard-knock wife she's
also one of the stars of the Netflix
rom-com always be my maybe think you
know who she is it's Ali Wong she was
stoked to play officer gore because
she's one of the first openly gay
characters in a Disney movie but this
isn't Ali's only Disney voiceover credit
she was also the voice of felony in
Ralph's breaks the internet and she says
she's always down for more animation you
know some kids play rougher than others
so before she was shepherding sheep the
actress who voices Bo Peep in Toy Story
4 was busy being a secretary in
ghostbusters now she plays Mima in young
Sheldon so who is she
it's Annie Potts and she's always been
Bo Peep she even voiced the character in
the recent lamp life short on Disney
plus one of Annie's biggest inspirations
is Dolly Parton so she loves any
opportunity to play a Bond icon even an
animated one like Bo this next actress
took on the role of bad dog Gabby Gabby
which is funny considering she now stars
in a show called good girls and her hair
in real life flips an awful lot like
Gabby Gabby's good choice around here
don't have kids are you too lost think
you know who she is
it's Christina Hendricks the fiery
redhead who starred in Mad Men
Christina loves playing a strong
powerful female character and you can
actually catch her in a new animated
movie that just released
she plays officer Jaffe in Scoob
duckie and bunny are the perfect
characters for two best bud comedians -
voice I don't care bear the BFFs who
voiced these characters fell into a deep
bromance as soon as they met then they
started a hit sketch comedy series
before starring in some solo projects
think you know who they are that's right
it's keegan-michael key and Jordan Peele
that are known together as key and Peele
the duo had fun improvising a lot of
their lines for the film one of their
favorite habits as friends is randomly
singing to each other so they just had
to sneak that into the movie did you
know that three of Braves characters
were voiced by Harry Potter stars let's
start with Merida this princess needed a
truly unique voice to bring her to life
and this Scottish born actress was the
perfect choice she had roles in Lassie
and even played Helena Ravenclaw in
Harry Potter any idea who she could be
it's Kelly Macdonald and she was so
proud to have starred in Pixar's very
first female lead movie she voiced
Merida again for a Ralph breaks the
internet because could you even imagine
anyone else in the role Japanese I
another Harry Potter start lent her
voice to Queen Eleanor she played Ollie
the parrot in Doolittle can you guess
who it is I asked you what do you expect
it's Emma Thompson she's a huge fan of
voiceover work and even voiced the elder
in the golden globe-winning film
missing link and of course she also
played divinations expert professor
Sybill Trelawney but we've saved the
most surprising Harry Potter star for
last this is the one you've all been
waiting for do you know which huge Harry
Potter star lent their voice to Lord
Dingwall here's your hint he is quite
literally huge think you know who it is
it's Robbie Coltrane better known as
Hagrid from the Harry Potter series
Robbie had so much fun working behind
the mic and bringing such a different
character to life and it was a lot less
work than his role as Hagrid you don't
always have to wear layers of heavy
robes when you're in a cozy recording
studio so how'd you do let us know how
many voices you got write in the comment
section down below we just can't wait to
be king
oh actually we can't wait for the Lion
King remake to be released seriously
though we have a feeling it's going to
be a good one have you been wondering
who will be voicing all of your
favourite characters in the 2019 new
movie keep watching to find out who is
behind the mic of the Lion King Donald
Glover first up is the star of the show
and everyone's favorite lion Simba is
going to be voiced by none other than
the extremely talented Donald Glover
Donald is more than just an actor he is
a writer musician comedian producer and
director
whoa that's a lot of roles he might have
heard him under one of his stage names
he goes by childish gambino dom got his
start as a writer on the sitcom 30 rock
then he got a role on the hit show
community which launched him into acting
fame you're Doogie Seacrest I think I'm
better than everyone else because I'm 40
I'm not 40 he currently is working as
the creator writer producer and star of
the TV show at land
this show is epic he won an Emmy for
outstanding actor in a comedy series for
his role back in 2017
you might also recognize him from
spider-man homecoming he also stole our
hearts as the young Lando Calrissian
from the Star Wars movie solo he's done
several stand-up comedy routines
he's also released several rap albums
under the name childish gambino
and they are amazing in 2018 he was
nominated for five Grammy Awards he won
Best traditional R&B performance Donald
Glover is one impressive guy and Time
magazine agreed in 2017 he was named one
of times 100 most influential people
everything you've heard about me is true
we can't wait to see how awesome he is
as Simba Seth Rogan Pumbaa is one of the
funniest Disney characters ever it makes
sense that one of the funniest comedy
actors will voice him and can you
imagine anyone more perfect for the role
than Seth Rogen he's got one of the most
recognizable faces in Hollywood and
definitely the most recognizable laugh
gotta start acting way back in 1999 he
played Ken Miller on the teen sitcom
freaks and geeks he had several roles in
the next few years but he really rose to
fame when he starred opposite Katherine
Heigl in the 2007 film knocked up Steph
is best known for his really offensive
and inappropriate comedy most of his
films are definitely not family-friendly
Seth doesn't just star in his films he
is also a screenwriter
he has worked a lot with director Judd
Apatow on films like Superbad and
pineapple Express he also acts with his
good friend James Franco they starred in
2014's the interview which was all about
a journalist to go into North Korea who
was a revelant and hilarious and it was
really controversial Seth isn't afraid
to make his audience uncomfortable for
the sake of comedy but he doesn't just
do adult comedy films he has done a lot
of voice acting before including
important tears of Hugh we just
no he's going to be a perfect Pumbaa
Billy Eichner Kumba's PFF is just as
funny of a character Timon the meerkat
is responsible for introducing Simba to
the philosophy of Hakuna Matata
so who is playing this very important
role in the new Lion King that honor
belongs to Billy Eichner who's that you
ask well you might be more familiar with
his voice than his face Billy Eichner
does a lot of voice acting he's played
chef pig in the Angry Birds movie he
played mr. Ambrose on several episodes
of Bob's Burgers biographies under E
thanks that's my job and I love it he
had a reoccurring role in Parks and
Recreation as craig middlebrooks if
you're into scary shows you might
recognize him as mutt nutter on American
Horror Story creepy Billy was also a
longtime performer with The Upright
Citizens Brigade that is a comedy improv
troupe that has given many famous stars
that start that includes stars like Amy
Poehler and Aziz Ansari Billy Eichner
isn't the only UCB alum in Lion King
Donald Glover was a member too we're
excited to hear I can earn Linda's voice
to the iconic meerkat baby for the last
time James Earl Jones most of the cast
in the new Lion King are brand new to
their roles but when you're as big of a
legend as James Earl Jones you get to
reprise your role as the original king
of the Lions James Earl Jones was the
original Mufasa way back in 1994 Surabhi
and I didn't see you at the presentation
of Simba and he's back to voice Simba's
father in 2019 we are so excited James
Earl Jones is a Hollywood icon he has
been acting since the 1950s Wow
where else have you heard his famous
voice Star Wars of course me
i James Earl has been the voice of Darth
Vader since the very first film he
reprised this role in rogue one in 2016
one of James Earls earliest films that
made him famous was the cult classic dr.
Strangelove from director Stanley
Kubrick James Earl is an amazing actor
and there is proof he is one of the only
fourteen people to be an eg OT
what's that you ask it means he has won
an Emmy a Grammy an Oscar and a Tony
pretty cool right James Earl has starred
in the 1995 movie pride the Beloved
Country which is based on the classic
novel about race in South Africa but
even though James Earl has one of the
most recognizable voices in Hollywood he
overcame a lot James Earl told ABC News
how he overcame a stutter oh yeah
and young gettin through it without
stuttering he has slowed down his acting
in recent years but you can often find
him at comic conventions where Star Wars
fans can get his autograph it's so cool
that he gets to play Mufasa again
Chiwetel Ejiofor up next is the evil
brother of Mufasa scar is the villain in
the Lion King but the actor who plays
him is far from a bad guy
Chiwetel Ejiofor is an awesome actor and
all-around a great person Chui Attalla
starred in some fantastic movies you
might recognize him from the intense
drama 12 years a slave in this 2013
movie he played Solomon Northup a free
black northerner who was kidnapped and
sold into slavery
Chiwetel received a lot of praise for
his heart-wrenching performance he also
had a role in the iconic film Amistad
in fact his role as in sine Covey was
only his second acting credit he doesn't
always play really serious historical
roles he played Peter in Love Actually
he also played more dough in dr. strange
this is the start
of the Living Tribunal the British actor
also enjoys stage acting he is played
Othello alongside Ewan McGregor he also
starred as Romeo in a production of
Shakespeare's Romeo and Juliet he's won
several stage awards Ejiofor is also a
philanthropist and activist he has done
some amazing charity in Nigeria The Lion
King isn't the only film that to a'tall
will be in this year he's directing and
starring in the boy who harnessed the
wind it is about a young boy who saves
his village in Africa by reading about
and building a windmill this will be his
first directorial role which he talks
about in the Sundance interview I think
I've always been kicking around with the
idea of writing something directing
something we are so excited to see him
as scar Beyonce
this next actress needs no introduction
none other than the Queen V is playing
Nala
Simba's love interest and we think
Beyonce Knowles is perfect for the role
Nala is a fierce independent character
it makes sense that Sasha Fierce would
voice her in the new movie
she tells 60 minutes Australia where the
fierce alter-ego came from I named her
Sasha actually my cousin named her Sasha
Beyonce is best known for her music
career she got her start as the lead
singer of Destiny's Child back in the
90s she broke off from the band and
began an incredibly successful solo
career her most famous song is single
ladies for which she was nominated for a
Video Music Award but Beyonce is no
stranger to acting she starred in
Dreamgirls alongside Jennifer Hudson
back in 2006 she also acted in the
remake of King hared there at the same
year it was falling apart so I had it
studded with diamonds to wear on stage
at the presidential wall The Lion King
will not be the first time that beyonce
has voiced an animated character either
she played Queen Tara in the film epic
this was about a girl who gets shrunk
and learns there's a whole kingdom of
tiny creatures living in her backyard
she has won several Grammy Awards and
she has been voted one of People
Magazine's Most Beautiful People beyonce
is married to rapper jay-z and they have
three children she is still one of the
most successful female artists of all
time
we can wait to hear her
is our favorite lioness John Connie next
up we have the voice of Rafiki Rafiki is
the eccentric monkey and shaman who
advises Mufasa he's the one who holds up
Simba as a baby to all the animals of
the plain
Rafiki is going to be plagued by the
iconic John Connie
you probably recognize John from his
role in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
he plays teach Shaka the king of Wakanda
and father of two chala in the Captain
America Civil War he also makes an
appearance in a flashback during Black
Panther the South African actor has
played some amazing roles I am grateful
to the Avengers for supporting this
initiative John has been acting since
1974 and he's got a really extensive
filmography he also has done plenty of
stage acting in the 70s he won a Tony
Award for his Broadway performance in
seas way Bondi is dead and the island
John has also done some Shakespearean
acting he was in the 2011 film
Coriolanus which was directed by Ralph
Fiennes John can act in pretty much any
type of role it takes a talented guy to
be able to play a Shakespeare role and a
super hero we bet he will be an awesome
Murphy key alfre woodard we know who is
playing Simba's dad but who is playing
his mom Surabhi the role belongs to the
lovely alfre woodard even if you don't
know her name we bet you recognise her
face Africa's been acting for decades
she had her first role back in the 1970s
so where have you seen her recently she
has played Mariah Dillard on Marvel's
Luke Cage I don't
that's the truth that isn't her first
experience with Marvel she had a small
role in Captain America Civil War and
while she may not have been in the
recent movie Black Panther she's no
stranger to Vacanti in 2010 there was an
animated miniseries about the African
superhero
Alfre voiced the Queen Mother and
several other characters I have lived
plenty son I would die fighting
Alfre has done a lot of TV acting she
played Ruby Jean Reynolds the mother of
Lafayette on True Blood she also played
the president on state of affairs in
2014 and 2015
she has guest-starred on Empire a few
times too like her Lion King co-star
Beyonce she's been named one of People
Magazine's Most Beautiful People she has
several films coming out in 2019 we are
excited that she is joining other
awesome actors in the Lion King John
Oliver one of the funniest characters in
the original Lion King is Zazu this
hornbill bird is mufasa's closest
advisor he's sarcastic and no-nonsense
and he is very frustrated by Simba we
were excited to learn that John Oliver
is voicing Zazu in the remake he has the
perfect voice for the grumpy bird which
you can see in his latest trailer for
last week tonight $6 for possibly the
largest raisin bran flakes in the world
jon is best known as a comedian and a
late-night host he got his start on The
Daily Show and The Colbert Report before
he getting his own show last week
tonight with John Oliver started in 2014
but even though he usually appears on TV
as himself he's no stranger to acting he
guest-starred on several episodes of
community he also voiced the role of
vanity Smurf in the 2011 Smurfs movie as
well as its sequel John is also a
successful writer he wrote for nearly
1,000 episodes of The Daily Show he has
an extensive history with stand-up
comedy too
John Oliver is not funny
oh poor John we think you're funny he
brings humor to serious issues like
politics he attributes his success to
after Ricky Gervais psious who
recommended the comedian to John Stewart
Stewart was the longtime host of The
Daily Show without that role John would
not have been nearly as successful as he
is today we can't wait to see him bring
his quick wit and biting sarcasm to Zazu
it's going to be epic
JD McCreary okay we know that Donald
Glover is playing Simba but he is only
playing the adult Simba in the original
movie a child actor played the voice of
young Simba but that child actor
Jonathan Taylor Thomas is all grown up
so who is playing the new young Simba
it looks like JD McCleery is the cub who
just can't wait to be king you might
have seen him perform at the Grammys
with Donald Glover his Lion King co-star
he talks all about his career in an
interview with Kate I is fm
then they said um do you want to perform
at the Grammys with Donnell Glover and
of course we said yes it's the Grammys
come on JD has been acting since 2014 he
has several small roles including a
Disney Channel guest appearance
he played young Ernie on Casey
Undercover it was just a really big
moment for me because I that like you
have to start somewhere he had a few
other guest appearances on TV shows one
of those was an episode of teachers in
2018 he got a role on the pains he
played Kenny Payne
well I'm busy so go on and do and the
kid can sing on a 20-19 episode of
American souls he played a young Michael
Jackson he is also in another movie that
is releasing later this year called
little he's definitely off to a great
start
we just know we are going to keep seeing
great things from JD as he gets older
shall hottie right Joseph last but
certainly not least is the actress who
plays young Nala this actress is pretty
new to Hollywood but she is going places
Shahani right Joseph only has four
acting credits to her name right now her
first role was on hairspray live this
was a live TV version of the famous
musical Hairspray
she said it was the most fun ever in an
interview with black Hollywood live I
had the best time of my life it was so
exciting and so much fun everybody there
was so sweet and so nice it looks like
fun
the story deals with an overweight girl
in the sixties who wants to be on a
local TV show it also deals with some
serious race issues specifically
discrimination in television Shahani
plays little Inez the little sister of
one of the main characters and this girl
has an amazing voice she told Alexis joy
VIP access that she loved the
choreography too I especially love all
of the choreography and the music and
the cast was so sweet
AHA Dee has three more movies coming out
soon which he hints at in the black
hollywood live interview well I might be
moving to LA for us will be released in
2019 just like Lion King and she is
currently filming a movie called
dreamers we are so pumped to hear her
voice in the new Lion King movie we have
a feeling we'll be seen a lot more from
Shahaji right Joseph over the next
several years the loud house wouldn't be
a hit without the remarkable talents
that bring the characters to life these
unseen stars make the show what it is so
let's get to know them a little more
you'll never believe which loud sister
shares a voice with a Star Wars
character if this is your first time
visiting our channel go ahead
hit that subscribe button don't forget
to give this video a big thumbs up now
let's take a look at the voices behind
the loud house character my dad say I
have a million dollars my khalil Harris
and Andre Robinson
Clyde McBride is Lincoln lounge brainy
besties his role in the show provides
quite a lot of funny moment the show
needs Clyde and Clyde needs his voice
unlike most characters on the show
applied has been voiced by two actors
Khalil Harris played Clyde for the first
three seasons of the show this talented
kid has appeared in numerous films and
TV series including the hit Castle Rock
Khalil has been praised for his
carefully chosen roles he voices the
character Franklin in peanuts that
character is historically important as
peanuts was the first comic strip to
tell the story of racially inclusive
friends Khalil was replaced on the loud
house in season three by Andre Robinson
Andre took over when Khalil's voice
began to change as he got older Andre
was already a star by the time he came
to the loud house he had roles in huge
movies like fences and hidden figures he
picked up Clyde where Khalil left off
and ran with the roll grant Palmer and
Colin Dean some fans would argue that
the loud house is all about only brother
Lincoln so much of the story centers
around him and his troubles with so many
sisters if Lincoln is the main character
that makes the actors who've played him
the Stars Grant Palmer played Lincoln
for the first 22 episodes of the show
grant is from California and believe it
or not his mom's name is Laurie Grant's
voice changed as he got older and was
replaced by Colin Dean Colin has
actually played link in the longest he's
been on the show for a total of 66
episode he's the only actor who's played
Lincoln for an entire season it's been
confirmed by the show that Colin will be
replaced by Tex Hammond Jack's played
Lincoln in one episode of the show's
podcast he released a youtube video
announcing he landed the role but took
it down one day later you might find it
surprising that such an important
character has been played by so many
actors it's pretty standard for shows to
recast a role especially when the actors
are kids young boy's voice has changed
so much as they grow up that it's hard
for them to play the roles of little
kids for long Wayne Brady
the loud house has a pretty impressive
cast Wayne Brady is another of the
multi-talented powerhouses that make
this show so great Wayne never planned
on becoming
actor he had his heart set on a career
in the military a chance performance in
high school launched his acting career
Wayne is a singer stage actor film actor
voice actor and comedian Wayne isn't
afraid to tackle tough work his role on
the loud house is no different he
proudly plays Harold McBride Harold and
Howard are one of the first married male
couples in cartoon history their roles
are super important
just like Franklin and peanuts the
McBride family provides some important
representation there are lots of kids
with two dads who now get to see a
family like theirs in a fantastic show
having a talented actor in such an
important role is one of the many things
that makes this show such a hit Wayne
has won many awards including an Emmy
you may recognize him from his frequent
appearances on whose line is it anyway
Gradle I'll like a few other actors in
the loud house Gradle I'll plays more
than one role she plays Lola Lana and
Lily loud it really shows off her talent
that she voices three totally different
characters on the same show gray has a
huge resume that includes over 1,000
credits in over 300 titles her talent
seems to have been passed on to her son
text Haman who we spoke about before is
set to take over the role of Lincoln and
guess who's his mom that's right grade-a
Lyle she's played a total of 18 other
roles on the loud house as well as three
of the loud sister you may recognize her
as the voice of Mandy from the grim
adventures of Billy and Mandy that role
was a natural choice for gray as she
loved goth music as a teenager gray is
also a talented senior her musical
career sparked her interest in comedy as
well
as a comedian she developed an
impressive talent for impressions being
an impressionist was a short leap from
being a voice actor and soon she was
lending her voice to a massive range of
projects anyone who can play over 1,000
different characters is obviously very
talented John DiMaggio the loud house
cast is definitely star-studded there's
no denying that the shell is voiced by
the biggest names in the business John
DiMaggio is no exception this guy is a
voice acting megastar he provides the
iconic voice of bender on Futurama as
well as Jake the dog on adventure time
those two roles alone are enough to earn
him a spot and voice acting history he
has 830 credits to his name he was an
executive producer of know that voice
a documentary about voice acting he's
been on shows like Johnny Bravo
Powerpuff Girls and Teen Titans John
plays over 15 characters on the loud
house
John's famous for his gruff voice and
his ability to fake a Brooklyn accent
the star isn't even from New York but
nearby New Jersey his talent has won him
a ton of awards including a Kids Choice
Award his career shows no signs of
slowing down he landed a huge role on
the Netflix hit disenchantment the loud
house is obviously full of talent John
is a perfect example of just how
incredible the cast is Jessica - Chico
Lucy loud gets her voice from Jessica -
Chico Jessica also plays Lynne you might
think it's hard to play two characters
at once but jessica is a seasoned pro
she has almost 100 roles under her belt
can you imagine playing that many
characters she doesn't just play Lucy
and Lynne either Jessica's dad was an
actor when she was a kid she grew up
around show business in New York City
her career started when she was chosen
from thousands of other school kids to
appear in a TV special after that
Jessica's career took off no one in this
family ever willingly lets me do
experimental Nana Laura Jill Miller
Laura Jill Miller provides the voices
for both Lisa loud and Liam Lara is the
only main voice actor who's been
credited in every combined episode
segment she plays 17 other roles on the
show as well that's a ton of characters
on just one show Lara had appeared in 47
different titles and portrayed 80
separate characters Miss Pennsylvania
native played the adorable Lambie on doc
McStuffins and won herself a gaggle of
fans her role as Lisa is just as popular
Laura had won a lot of awards as a voice
actor she's a talented star who makes
her characters shine
with a show as huge as the loud house on
a resume she's sure to impress wherever
she goes
Lilliana moo me many of the actors on
the loud house played iconic characters
before working on the show Liliana
Mooney is one of them she played the
unforgettable Myrtle Edmonds in lilo and
Stitch even bullies have their fans and
Myrtle is a beloved brat that wasn't
Liliana's only big role she also played
panini in
chowder and appeared in bravest warriors
and barnyard she's acted in front of the
camera as well with roles in the Santa
Clause - and Cheaper by the Dozen she
got her start at a young age child
acting runs in her blood her dad bill
Mumy starred in lost in space when he
was a kid and even appeared in an
episode of The Twilight Zone it's no
surprise she's so talented with a dad
like that on the loud house she provides
the voice of Leni as well as a few minor
roles Liliana delivers a fantastic
performance as the absent-minded and
ditzy Lenny the second-oldest loud
sister is sweet and beautiful she makes
us laugh with silly lines
mispronunciations and excellent comedy
delivery all of that awesomeness
wouldn't exist if it weren't for
Liliana's talent she perfectly
demonstrates the characters good nature
and love for her family Nika Futterman a
few voice actors on the loud house have
also lent their voices to Star Wars
characters that's the case for Anika
Futterman - she plays the role of Luna
loud like many of the other actors she's
played a few roles on the show in
addition to one of the loud sisters
she's played over 240 characters in her
career Nika is from New York City and is
very proud of her Jewish heritage she
would go on to act in many cartoons
including cat dog Hey Arnold Teen Titans
go and many more she played the
character in several animated series and
related video games - the Star Wars
franchise attracts a lot of talented
actors it makes sense that so many Louds
share their voices with characters from
the animated films and games Nika plays
the musical loon allowed her casting is
no surprise as Nika herself is a
talented musician imagine Luna on stage
with rock stars Kathryn Tabor Laurie
loud gets her big personality from voice
actor Kathryn Tabor this Georgia native
is a star both behind the scenes and in
front of the camera
unlike some voice actors Kathryn got her
start in the movies she starred in the
film the girls room and even co-starred
in just like heaven with Reese
Witherspoon Kathryn has lent her voice
to over eight animated projects
including the loud house Laurie isn't
even the only character she's played on
the show she has voiced 12 other roles
plus Laurie Lewis she was the voice of
Amidala in Star Wars the Clone Wars
she was also Princess Leia
in Star Wars detours sci-fi fans love
Kathryn and some even refer to her as a
gate goddess she's even been a voice
actor in several video games
her voice is found in at least 20
different titles her love of games
doesn't stop at playing them or
appearing in them catherine started in
organization called games for soldiers
this group accepts donations of video
games and comic books for soldiers
deployed in Iraq and Afghanistan how
cool is that she's a talented actor and
a super nice person
Laurie loud just wouldn't be the same if
she were voiced by anyone else Wow
seriously I just have to ask you how are
you pulling this off are you a genius at
guessing celeb voices then why don't you
give some of these underrated characters
a try from the movie that ariana grande
and bella thorne starred in together to
Kristen Bell's cool cameo in Zootopia
this list is full of your favorite stars
and the movies they rocked
there's even an animated flick that
reunited three huge Nickelodeon stars
but can you guess who they are let's
dive in and find out oh my gosh this is
gonna be so much fun the actors who
voiced Jay in the Angry Birds movie 2 is
best known for being an amazing role
model and also for her time on Dance
Moms she's had a special on Nickelodeon
where we got to peek inside of her world
and she's recorded hit songs like
boomerang so what's your best guess it's
the iconic Jojo cui who didn't only
voice hatchling J in the hit movie but
also Keira the eagle she spoke to just
Jared jr. about her characters and said
that the trickiest part was matching her
voice over to the already completed
animation she also told them that she
hopes J eventually gets her own spin-off
and we'd love to see it
[Music]
Disney Channel star took on the role of
Ella in the same movie this actress is
an amazing singer best known for roles
in descendants and Liv and Maddie she's
also a phenomenal live performer she
brought her skills to hairspray live in
the role of amber Von Tussle do you
think you know who she is
of course it's dub Cameron Disney
Channel royalty who's definitely got the
whole package
doves role as Ella isn't her only voice
acting credit she also voiced a
superhero she's the voice of
when Stacey also known as spider-gwen in
the ultimate spider-man and marvel
rising TV shows dishing out punishment
they never stopped to ask me if I was
actually guilty you definitely know the
actor chosen to voice chuck another
Angry Birds character he starred in the
live-action Beauty and the Beast and he
was on Broadway in the Book of Mormon
but his best role probably the voice of
Olaf in Disney's frozen think you know
who it is yep that's right it's Josh GAD
he also voiced Lewis in ice age
continental drift and Damon on Bob's
Burgers he was also Wendell the bug in
Phineas and Ferb plus Josh and Kristen
Bell who voices onna in frozen just
reunited in Central Park a new animated
show on Apple TV kitchen and of course
downward duck this Disney Channel
superstar brought his iconic voice to
Lou in ugly dolls you're probably used
to seeing him with his brothers on stage
and in movies like camp rock so who is
he it's Nick Donis our childhood crush
who can pretty much make our hearts melt
with one word so we're not upset at all
that he's been getting into voice acting
he and his brothers had another surprise
voice acting cameo when they were pretty
young but stick around because we'll
tell you more about that a little bit
later of course of course stay here this
singer co-starred with Nick as the
character Tuesday she's super new to
acting and voice acting so you probably
only heard of her from her many
successful songs including in the name
of love and I'm gonna show you crazy
think you know who she is
it's bebe Rexha who was also the writer
behind some hit singles like Eminem and
Rihanna 'he's the monster her role as
Tuesday led to her starring in her very
first movie but with a voice like that
we'd love to see bebe show off her
skills in another feature animation this
camp rock star won the role of Smurfette
in Smurfs The Lost village she's a
phenomenal singer whose recent single
anyone made huge waves at the 2019
Grammy Awards and she used to be really
good friends with Selena Gomez the two
of them even starred in a Disney Channel
original movie together any idea who she
could be its Demi Lovato
the actress turned singer who loved
playing Smurfette because they're both
fierce and resourceful Demi actually
voiced another animated character in the
movie charming
she played Lenore and was joined by a
fellow Disney Channel star Ashley
Tisdale who voiced Cinderella
we're Smurfs we do the right thing the
role of Smurf lily went to this modern
family star who has a talent for voice
acting she's also appeared in ER and RL
Stine's the haunting hour and she just
so happens to have the same name as a
Disney Princess who do you think it is
it's Ariel winter who's super well known
as Alex Dunphy but she's no stranger to
voice acting she starred in tons of kids
TV shows though you probably know her
best as gretchen in phineas and ferb and
penny in mr. Peabody and Sherman we have
to take you to smurfy Grove
snowflake the white gorilla is a fun
underrated movie that stars one of the
world's most famous singers as snowflake
she's known for her role in Nickelodeon
shows like victorious and she's also
known for saying thank you next that's
right
it's ariana grande we thought you didn't
know that she starred alongside iCarly's
jennette mccurdy who voiced petunia and
nathan kress who voiced Elvis but this
isn't Ariana's first big animated
reunion with fellow childhood stars
Bella Thorne may be a Disney star but
she joined Ariana as the young version
of her character Laura in the underdogs
movie take him down you'll play one of
Saturday Night Live's biggest cast
members took on the role of Lupe the
eccentric goat in Ferdinand she also
does a really good impression of Ellen
DeGeneres hmm
any guesses it's Kate McKinnon playing
Lupe was a dream come true for Kate and
she wants the character to teach kids
that sing true to yourself is totally
worth it
and fun fact Kate's actually super good
friends with Ellen she even got a role
in Ellen's latest flick finding dory try
some deep relaxing breaths okay in this
superstar who voiced Queen Tara in epic
can be described as a queen in real life
she's an iconic singer and she starred
in movies like dream girls so who is she
it's the one and only Beyonce who you
shouldn't even be surprised as taking on
voice acting in addition to
all of her other amazing talents she was
recently the voice of Nala in the Lion
King live-action remake she also helped
put together the movies entire
soundtrack where a performer that's so
incredible in front of an audience she
sure seems just as comfortable behind
the scenes I might have a hard time
picking one do you have a favorite
this next actress is a surprisingly good
singer which is why she got to voice ash
the rock star porcupine insane so you
probably know her better as an ethic
Avenger she's actually voiced a lot of
animated characters before like princess
Mindy in the spongebob squarepants movie
think you know who she could be its
Scarlett Johansson this Black Widow
loved being in a film about following
your dreams it's definitely a lighter
role than some of her other ones she was
the voice of the sinister snake ha in
the live-action Jungle Book which is a
huge deal because all the original movie
characters were meal and they came to
Scarlett for the role so that they could
get more women involved in the remake
you do yes would you like to see since
sing is pretty big on girl power
they got another epic powerhouse will
bliss to voice Minah you might remember
her from season 9 of American Idol she's
also won a Grammy for Best gospel album
for hiding place and she's appeared on
Sesame Street any guesses
it's the amazing Tori Kelly with the
voice of an angel it's no wonder she was
the perfect pick Romina her favorite and
also the most stressful part of the
whole process was putting her own spin
on hallelujah this was her very first
voice acting role but since Tori loved
the experience she'll probably pop up in
another animated flick sometime soon no
I mean yes another powerhouse actress
took on the role of wife mother and
secret singer Rosita this actress has
been Legally Blonde for most of her life
but we all knew she could pull off
singing thanks to her well-received role
in walk the line
so what's your best guess of course it's
Reese Witherspoon
she loved the opportunity to play a
mother who proves that she is so much
more than a housewife but seeing isn't
Reese's first shot at voice acting she
also voiced Susan Murphy in monsters vs.
aliens
look I can't even keep counted the steps
my body parts aren't responding okay
she's a superstar singer with her own
makeup line but she was also the voice
of tip in the movie home back in the day
she was singing phoned a replay do you
know her it's Rihanna
the fenty queen who also has some great
voice acting chops she co-starred in
this flick with the Big Bang Theory's
Jim Parsons who kept cracking her up
behind the scenes the actors to voice
tips mother Lucy is also a successful
singer she's known for getting people on
the floor and she gave a wicked Super
Bowl performance in 2019 we think you
know who this superstar is it's Jennifer
Lopez another woman who can really do it
all JLo's no stranger to starring in
movies but did you know that she was
also the voice of Shira in the Ice Age
movies as for her role in home she was
chosen to record the movies theme song
feel the light this world famous pop
star used to do a little acting back in
the day when she took on the role of
Audrey in the Lorax she's been in
Valentine's Day and was featured singing
in Hannah Montana the movie any idea who
she could be its singer-songwriter
Taylor Swift she co-starred with Zac
Efron and the two had a blast behind the
scenes while she was recently in cats
she hasn't done a lot of acting lately
let us know in the comments where you'd
like to see taylor next those are trees
they used to grow all around here we
know this voice actress really well she
may have voiced the tiny role of
Priscilla the sloth in Zootopia but
she's had a whole bunch of iconic roles
and she's also one of our favorite
Disney Princesses from frozen so who is
she
you're right it's totally Kristen Bell
she is absolutely addicted to sloth
so the small role of Priscilla was a
no-brainer for her another underrated
role that you might not know Kristen
took on is Harper Jim house key one of
Lisa's rich friends in the Simpsons we
thought you didn't know about this
friend star who voiced Sarah Gardner in
storks in the popular sitcom she was
known for her iconic hair and fashion
sense any idea who she could be it's the
one and only Jennifer Aniston she
admitted that the
most nerve-wracking part of taking the
role was having to hear her own voice in
surround sound don't be crazy you cannot
do the chimney the Brooklyn nine-nine
star who voiced Jonathan in Hotel
Transylvania 3 has done pretty much
everything he's been on Saturday Night
Live in a very lonely band and he's
starred in movies like hot rod and pop
star never stopped never stopping think
you know who he is
that's right it's Andy Samberg Andy has
had tons of voiceover roles and you
probably didn't realize that most of
these were him he was Brent McHale in
Cloudy with a Chance of Meatballs and
jr. in stores he was bred in Bob's
Burgers and Ricky the Raptor in American
Dad who knew that legendary sea monsters
could be such good fingers for the role
of the Kraken the Hotel Transylvania
crew needed a hip young artist and it
doesn't hurt that he's pretty close
friends with co-star Selena Gomez oh and
did we mention this superstar is best
known for rocking out in a band with his
brothers and that he's also married to a
start
if you guessed Joe Jonas then you got it
right this Jonas Brother was the perfect
choice for a crooning Kraken but you
might be surprised to find out that this
isn't Joe's first or most underrated
voice acting role he and his brothers
voiced the cherubs in Night at the
Museum battle of the Smithsonian where
they also got to show off their
signature singing voices in fact to get
things just right the brothers want to
chair a boot camp that sounds like a
once-in-a-lifetime experience does he
gets the groove going and everyone's got
a great time
which of these voice actors on our list
is your favorite let us know what other
animated movies you'd love to go behind
the scenes of in the comments section
down below don't forget to hit that like
button if you enjoyed this video and
subscribe to the scenes for more thanks
for watching we'll see you next time